I spend just 60 minutes a day trading
and on a good day I can make over $5,000
in that [music] single hour. But I
didn't start risking thousands of
dollars per trade. I originally built
this strategy just risking $50 per
trade. And recently I went back to prove
it again and turned a $50 account into
over $3,500 in just 21 days using this
exact same system I still use today. And
what most people don't realize is you
can actually get started with as little
as $4 now. Learn the strategy that I'm
doing with tiny risk and scale it step
by step all the way to trading even
larger size than I do now. The strategy
is super simple. The time commitment is
small enough that it works even if you
have a full-time job. So, let's get into
exactly how you can start day trading
with just $4 and what the growth path
actually looks like to scale from that
tiny risk all the way to trading at the
level I am now. So, we're going to go
over the four major steps to get you
started on this process. what you
actually want to be trading, how to get
started trading with just $4 of risk,
what your trading plan will actually be,
and then how to actually scale your
account to making consistent money.
Because again, when you first start out
trading, it's not about making money
initially. It's about practicing your
strategy and learning and then you can
get to a point where I am where you are
risking a lot of money but making even
more. So, what are you actually going to
trade? Because there are so many things
and assets in the market that you can
trade successfully. You can trade
stocks, you can trade options, you can
trade forex, you can trade crypto, and
we're actually not going to trade any of
those. We're actually going to trade
futures. And if you don't know what
these are, they are just another trading
asset like crypto, forex, stocks, or
options for starting with a small
account, beginning traders. And as well,
they allow you to scale over time. You
can basically trade 24/7 with them if
you want. You know, again, I only trade
60 minutes a day, but you can trade
these more if you want. There's no small
account restrictions. That's the problem
with trading stocks is a lot of times
you have run into something called the
pattern day trading rule where you need
over $25,000 in your account to
consistently place a lot of day trades.
Now, like I was talking earlier, it's
super scalefriendly.
Just to pull up a quick chart here, you
can be risking under $20 on some of
these trades, but then you can also
increase your risk way more. So, you can
start small, but then you can also do
the exact same thing. And you can see
these charts look the exact same, but
here I'm risking $1,500 instead of that
$20. And so, it allows you to execute
the exact same system on the exact same
chart, but just scaling and changing
your size, which makes that process of
scaling extremely fluid. Now what
futures markets are is they are
extremely liquid markets which makes
them really powerful for actually
trading. You're not trading something
like a penny stock or an option spread
that can be really illquid where you can
have fill issues. You can lose money
based on fees or spreads. These are the
most liquid markets in the world and so
you don't have to deal with any of that.
You're trading things like the NASDAQ,
the S&P 500, oil, gold, these huge
markets you hear about all the time, but
instead of trading the actual index,
you're trading a derivative of them just
called futures. And all futures are is
they're essentially a contract agreement
to buy one of these commodities at a
future price. And so that kind of sounds
complicated, but to show you the reality
of what this looks like, here's a trade
I recently took where I'm trading the
S&P 500 on a one minute chart. And you
can see it looks like and it produces
candles just like any other market. And
you can actually bet the market's going
to go down or you can bet that it's
going to go up. And so here's an example
where I'm making money as it goes down.
And so that's the beauty of trading
futures is you can get really big
leverage like options, but if you've
ever looked at options, they are
extremely complex and there's so much
that is so frustrating about them. And
futures are so much simpler. They're
just as simple as stocks. You basically
enter here, bet the market's going to go
down, and you make money as it goes
down. There's nothing complicated or
added about this and you essentially
trade exactly what you see on the chart
versus options have so many other
variables. And so I find it extremely
more powerful to do that. And again,
there's the scaling that comes into
play. And so you can see here I'm at
large size. And so this allows you to
make a a crazy amount of money in just a
few minutes here. Each one of these
candles is one minute. And so over, you
know, 1530 minutes here, I am, you know,
up just over $5,000 and it eventually
closes out here. But that's the beauty
of it is you're able to easily manage to
trade on the chart, get out when you
want to, and it doesn't have a lot of
complexities as other markets. And
again, I'll show you how you can get
started with a really small amount of
money here in a second. And so let's go
on to step two now where we can talk
about scaling your account. How you can
start with a really small amount of
money with $4 and then the process of
scaling and the steps you're going to
take. So there's three main options you
can take to get access to trading and
practicing it and then starting to make
money. Now the first one is demo
trading. You can get started with this
for as little as zero to $4. And this is
what I always highly recommend people
doing because when you're first starting
out, especially something new like
futures or any other market asset or
strategy, you're going to make mistakes.
And I have countless people that have
emailed me saying they started out
risking a lot of money, tens of
thousands, and they've lost it all
because they're just making beginner
mistakes. And so, you have to get
started with demo trading first and then
when you become confident, scale. And
we'll talk a little bit about that
process in a second. Now, a huge option
that you'll see is prop firms. And in my
eyes, these are a trap. They will
generally cost you at least $50 to $100
per month or more. The concept of them
is really awesome, but in the execution,
they work against you. And so the
concept of how they work is you pay a
fee to get access to a funded account
where they essentially say, "Hey, here
is $50,000 and you can trade with this
money and if the profits you make with
that money, you will keep a small
percentage." And so they will allow you
to do this for a monthly fee generally.
Like here's a great example of a prop
firm that will give you a $50,000
account, $150,000 account for a monthly
fee. And so the riskreward of, hey, I
can just risk $200 a month, but I get
access to this $5,000 account and I even
if I make $5,000 or $1,000, that is
insanely good. [music] But the execution
of how this works, even if they'll often
give you a coupon code to make this 80%
off, that just gets you in the door.
There are so many other fees associated
with this that you are spending a lot of
money consistently at the end of the day
to actually not trade with real money.
You are demo trading anyway because they
have it to where you are trying to pass
these challenges. You have to pass
multiple levels of challenges before you
actually unlock a real money account and
can get real payouts. And there is
literally statistics that under 5% of
people over time pass these challenges.
And so really what you're doing is
you're just paying a couple hundred a
month to [music]
demo trade because they're dangling a
piece of cheese in front of you like a
mouse. And so I highly recommend staying
away from these because it's just going
to cost you a lot of money when you can
just be paying 0 to $4 a month to do the
exact same thing. Now, if you really
want to do this, I'm not going to fully
knock on it. If you start demo trading
first and then you prove that you can be
consistently profitable demo trading
over a couple months, then you can
switch to prop firms and try it out. But
again, keep in mind and be aware that
the way they're set up is not to allow
you to win. they actually want you to
lose money because it's in their
business model and best interest too.
And so instead of doing prop firms, I
would recommend starting your own
brokerage account with futures. You can
do this for as little as $300 to $1,000,
maybe even less, but that's a really
good starting amount. And what this does
is it allows you to increase this slowly
from zero money risk of demo trading to
a small amount like we saw $20 of risk.
People don't realize initially and what
you'll learn over time is trading is
very very mental. Risking money is hard.
If I go back to this example I was
showing, you have to be able to handle
seeing this amount of money move. This
candlestick right here is like a $1,000
swing. And I didn't start being able to
handle that originally, right? I've
slowly built up to this over time
starting at that small amount of risk.
But that's where the mental side of
trading comes in. And so even if you
pass with a prop firm, you will be all
of a sudden having to deal with these
huge money swings with these prop firms
when you haven't done the training
essentially to build up to this. I have
so many trades where I was risking $50,
$100, $300, $500, $1,000, and now I'm
risking $1,500, and I'm close to sizing
up to $2,000 or $2,500. It's a slow
building process to get there. And so,
that's another reason why people fail
with prop firms is cuz you go from
risking nothing to a crazy amount. Even
if you're not risking it, think about it
on the flip side. The amount of money
that you can make is still in your brain
and messes with you. [music] And so
that's why it's the most important thing
to start this process like this. There
are no shortcuts in trading. [music]
Anyone who tells you otherwise is trying
to get your money in some way. Now,
let's go on to step three of building
your trading plan and your robust
system. So, there's a few key things
about creating a successful trading
plan. The first thing is you have to
choose your time frame to actually
trade. And so for me, what I do is I'm
day trading and so I'm trading on a one
minute chart a lot of the time, but I
also use a 15-minute chart to look at
the big picture because what you'll
realize over time is the small little
patterns are not as important as
understanding the big picture. The big
picture always is the most important
thing. Now, what you want to do is you
want to figure out how long you're going
to trade each day. There's a lot of
different reasonings you'll go through
in your head of why I want to trade
longer versus shorter. Originally, a lot
of the time in the beginning, I thought,
hey, I should trade 6 hours a day
because that means I will capture more
trades and so I'll make more money. And
that's not really how trading works.
Instead, I've realized the sweet spot is
somewhere between one or two hours.
Because what you'll realize over time is
trading is a decision game. You are
making hundreds of decisions every hour,
even if it's to do nothing. And what
this does is it's very taxing mentally
over time. And so over time, you'll get
more and more tired and you'll make
worse and worse decisions. And so what
you want to do is I've realized is well
I would rather instead of trading this
whole time and by the end of my trading
session I'll just be making crappy
decisions. I'll probably put a loss on.
It's better to just trade in this
beginning amount of time where I am at
my peak performance and I'm going to
make the best decisions possible
consistently. Trading is a consistency
game. You have to show up every single
day and make the right decision. that is
really hard to do. And so figuring out
how long you're going to trade every day
is extremely crucial for that. And as
well, riskreward is really important
when it comes to trading. I used to
start out scalping to where I was
risking $100 to make 50. That is a
negative riskreward ratio, making it
really hard to consistently make money
because every time you lose, you wipe
out two trades. And so it's really
important to understand how win rate and
riskreward works and kind of where is
that sweet spot. And this is kind of
different for everyone. A lot of people
like a 1:1 riskreward ratio because it's
very easy to hit your profit target. It
happens quickly. I found the sweet spot
for me is 1:3 riskreward ratio. Now, of
course, this kind of depends on the
exact strategy you end up using, but for
me, this allows me to be profitable with
only a 30% win rate. And so, mentally,
that takes the stress off of every
single trade to be right. You are going
to lose trades in trading. And so, I
find it way easier to be risking $100 to
make $300 because it takes multiple
losses to wipe out one win. And when you
have a win, it puts a lot more money in
your account. And so mentally, it sets
you up in the right way. That's the
biggest thing I'm trying to do here for
you is set you up with the correct
foundation to approach trading properly.
There are so many ways to trade and
approach trading. But if you don't set
up some of these foundational things the
right way, you are going to get lost and
waste a ton of time trying to figure it
out. Now, the last big thing [music] is
your strategy and entry checklist that
you make. Every time you jump into a
trade, you want to have a plan of what
you're doing, why you're jumping in,
where you're going to get out, if it's a
loss or a win, and how you're going to
consistently repeat that every single
day. Because if you don't have something
like that, you're going to show up to
the market, be watching it, and reacting
to the price movement and trying to take
a long, trying to buy, trying to sell,
and capture as much of every move as
possible. This is a huge problem for me
and other new traders is you see all
these moves and you think, "Oh my god, I
can make money off of this move. I can
make money off of this move. this move
over here, you know, oh, I I I don't
want to miss out on this move. And what
that ends up doing is you just end up
losing money because you're being
reactionary to the market versus having
a plan, looking for a specific thing
every single day and executing on that
plan when the market comes to you. That
is the biggest light bulb moment I had
in my trading is not trying to make
money from the market every single day.
instead having a strategy that I know
that makes money when it shows up and
waiting for that strategy to show up and
the market to fit that checklist that I
created. And so that's literally all I
do every day is I have an entry
checklist that I look for the five key
things and if it shows up I take a trade
and if it doesn't I just move on with my
day. For me in my strategy, I would
probably take one to three trades a
week. And the reason why is because
really good setups don't show up that
often, but I am patiently waiting for
them. And when they happen with the
beauty of trading and scaling and size,
well, you can make a crazy amount of
money from them. And so, you don't need
them to show up very often. I think
that's another huge trap that I fell
into and a lot of beginning traders fall
into is because they're day trading,
they want to be taking five to 10 trades
a day. They want it to be really
exciting, fast-paced, crazy amount of
money. And that's actually not how a lot
of really good traders trade. And at the
end of the day, trading is boring, and
it should be boring [music] because
that's how good trading works. And
that's how you're going to be able to
mentally handle trading long-term. And
just quickly to walk through this
five-step entry checklist on this trade
I had is literally every single morning
the market opens up at 9:30 Eastern
Standard Time. It's actually 7:30 my
time, 6:30 a.m. Pacific time, which
makes it super easy to do this before a
full-time job. especially on the West
Coast, you can literally be done trading
by 7 7:15 and then go on with your day.
But how it works is all I look for with
my trading is reversal trades. I look
for a move up to reverse betting that
it's going to go lower or I look for a
move down to reverse betting that it's
going to go higher. I don't look for a
breakout trade or a continuation trade
because I've realized that again
everything with trading the simpler the
better. And so with this trade
specifically, there was a big move that
the market had in the morning. And so I
was looking for that to reverse. And so
the market had a really nice trend here.
Looking at the swings of the market, it
was making higher highs and higher lows.
The market actually opened up right
here. And then from there, it made a
lower low here and a lower high. And
what I mean by these the major swings
here is an uptrend is, you know, made by
higher highs and higher lows. But when
it starts making lower highs and lower
lows, well, that is the structure of the
market telling you that it's going to
shift. And I found it way simpler to
just not use any indicators and just
read essentially the swings of the
market like that. Also, I have levels
here that are essentially reversal zones
of major support and resistance. Once
that happened is, you know, I looked for
a confirmation of a big bearish
candlestick. the market kind of broke
the lows of that candlestick and then I
bet that the market was going to go
lower. And you can see here there's a
couple support zones on the way down
that I'm looking as targets. I think,
okay, maybe the market will bounce up
here, but I can see and bet that maybe
it'll come down to this major support
zone. And so from there, you know, I
just manage to trade a little more
fluidly. I go to break even at some
point. It's really good to go break even
eventually to take risk off the table
because I don't know, you know, the
market could come down here and just
bounce and go up, right? And so there's
no point in me losing money on the trade
once it's got to a point where I think
it's shown that it will work out if it
does. And then from there, it's just
managing with the trend. You can see I
have a little downtrend line. And then
it starts to get really kind of
parabolic here to the downside. And I
trail my stop up pretty tightly because
you can see here at this point as it
spikes down here, I'm up basically
$6,000. but it pulls back to where I
close at $5,000. And so each one of
these candlesticks ends up being $1,000.
I don't want to have my stop all the way
up here and give too much back on the
trade. But I don't want to get into this
too much. That's for another video. But
this is the exact same strategy that I
used risking $50 per trade. You can
enter that exact same trade risking $50
or less. Now, let's go on to step four
of how to start with that small amount
of money and scale your account. Now,
the rough idea I like to tell people is
when you first start demo trading is you
want to see one to two months of
consistency trading on a demo account.
This gives you enough time to practice
reading the markets, practice your
strategy, practice entering, [music]
practice the trading platform you're
using before you switch to real money. I
know you really want to jump into real
money and actually start making money,
but don't focus on that right away. That
is what so many traders do that ends up
losing the money and washing them out of
trading because they get too excited and
jump too quickly into the real money.
What you want to do is focus on the
process, practicing your trading plan,
practicing the strategy, and
consistently daily executing and even
your trading routine. getting used to
waking up every day, opening up the
charts, analyzing the market, looking
for your exact strategy, and then also
practicing with calling it for the day.
It's hard to be done trading some days
when you get close to a trade or it
looks like there's going to be a trade
soon, but it hasn't shown up in your
trade window. Those are all mistakes
I've done before. And what I do now is
because of all these mistakes. Now when
it comes to real money and trading
platforms with futures is there's one
thing that futures have that is a little
different compared to trading options or
trading stocks, forex or crypto is
futures have something called margin.
All this is is just think of it like
collateral because you're buying a
leveraged asset. Why they're so powerful
is because they give you a lot of
leverage. They allow you to trade these
assets where generally to get access to
control that asset would be a lot of
money, but you're getting that same
movement for a fraction of the price.
But the beautiful thing about it, going
back to the chart, even though you're
getting a lot of leverage, you are still
able to keep your risk really small
based on putting your stop-loss in a
good spot. That's what you always want
to do with trades is you want to have a
good stop-loss. Now with margin and when
you get to opening a real brokerage
account is some of them have stuff
called intraday margin where if we look
at here to hopefully not have this be
too complicated for you as this is a
huge graph of a lot of them but what I
trade is the ES futures essentially the
S&P 500 futures and what futures have is
they have the larger version which is
called the E- mini and the micro version
which is the one you want to start out
with a [music] small account. And these
have the margin requirement to be really
small. $50 to get control of one
contract. Think of a contract like
buying a share. You know, in this trade
right here to show an example, I have
three contracts. That's all that's
showing is you're just buying that many
to get control to keep your risk at a
certain amount. And then when you, you
know, trade up to a larger amount, you
just need $500. And this is where it's
really powerful for a small account is
to get control of one contract. Like in
this example right here, if you
controlled one contract entering in here
with your stop loss here, you're only
risking under $20. You're not margin
isn't actually the risk on the trade.
It's just the collateral that you have
to put up. And so this can change based
on where you enter of how much you're
going to risk on one contract. But
that's the beauty of futures. Now, you
want to make sure that you go with a
broker that has these small intraday
amounts because if you look here, some
of them for here, you can see the normal
S&P 500 ES e- minis, they require
$14,000
and in intraday, they will generally be
half that at $7,000 versus the exact
same thing on some other platforms that
are smaller. It's $500. And then the
micro one would be 50. and the micro one
on this one would be still $700 just
because it's a tenth of the size of the
larger version. And so that's where the
beauty of being able to trade with a
small account. You just need to find the
right brokerage to do that. And don't
worry too much about fees because
they're pretty competitive across all
brokerages being roughly the same. The
biggest thing I always say about fees is
don't overtrade. That's where fees eat
you alive. If you are trading
infrequently, going for larger swings,
kind of like my strategy, fees do not
matter. That trade where I made $5,000,
I was at this fee rate. I think
technically I was even at a better fee
rate, but essentially I, you know, at
the worst case, it cost me $9 to make
that trade where I made $5,000. [music]
That's nothing, right? And so don't
worry too much about that if you are
trading a robust strategy that doesn't
overtrade like 20 trades a day. Now
where you can get started with all this
is the platform I've been showing you
and the platform I've used for over 5
years at this point is called Ninja
Trader. It's a futures trading focused
platform and it's the perfect place to
start practicing learning your strategy,
trading futures, and growing your
knowledge from there. I'll leave a link
in the description below for this as
well. It's the platform that allows me
to manage these trades very easily. You
can enter in essentially on the chart,
move your stop losses around by just
clicking this and dragging it. And
again, it's like I said, it's futures
focused. It's really, really powerful
for trading. This is where the $4 comes
in of how you can get started for just 0
to $4 is Ninja Trader actually will give
you live data for free for 14 days. All
you need is an email to sign up, but
after that, all you have to do is pay $4
to get access to data. other trading
platforms out there will cost $10 to $25
to get that same access just to demo
trade and that would be a monthly cost.
And so I highly recommend checking into
trader out to get started. Now, another
really good resource I've got for you is
a 90-day trader road map. I've gone
through and created essentially a full
step-by-step process of what you should
be doing in the first 90 days trading to
work towards becoming profitable,
scaling your account, starting trading,
and everything in between. Now, if you
want to learn more about futures, my
strategy, and take a deeper dive into
this process, I've got a complete deep
dive trading course here for free
that'll walk you through every step,
answer 90% of your questions for sure.
You can check that out right